your visions will become clear
only when you can look into your own
heart
who looks outside
dreams
who looks inside
awakes
until you make the unconscious conscious
it will direct your life
and you will call it fate
the pendulum of the mind oscillates
between sense and nonsense
not between right and wrong
the privilege of a lifetime
is to become who you truly are
the most terrifying thing is to accept
oneself
completely there's no coming to
consciousness without pain
show me a sane man
and i will cure him for you
no tree
it is said
can grow to heaven unless its roots
reach down to hell
in all chaos there is a cosmos
in all disorder
a secret order
mistakes are after all
the foundations of truth
and if a man does not know what a thing
is
it is at least an increase in knowledge
if he knows what it is not
man
is an animal that has gone mad
there are two ways out of this madness
he needs to become an animal again
or to become more than a person
the sexuality of man goes toward the
earthly
the sexuality of women
goes toward the spiritual
it is more polite to talk about sex
than to be embarrassed to talk about god
as far as we can discern
the sole purpose of human existence
is to kindle a light of meaning in the
darkness of mere being
where wisdom reigns
there is no conflict between thinking
and feeling
[Music]
how can i be substantial if i do not
cast a shadow
i must have a dark side also
if i am to be whole
the shoe that fits one person pinches
another
there is no recipe for living that suits
all cases
what you resist
persists
the reason for evil in the world
is that people are not able to tell
their stories
if there is anything that we wish to
change in the child
we should first examine it and see
whether it is not something that
could better be changed in ourselves
depression is like a woman in black
if she turns up
don't shoo her away
invite her in
offer her a seat
treat her like a guest
and listen to what she wants to say
the demon of sexuality
approaches our soul as a serpent
knights through dreams
tell the myths forgotten by the day
we meet ourselves time and again
in a thousand disguises on the path of
life
there can be no transforming of darkness
into light
and of apathy into movement without
emotion
if one does not understand a person
one tends to regard him as a fool
words are animals
alive with the will of their own
find out what a person fears most
and that is where he will develop
next without this playing with fantasy
no creative work has ever yet come to
birth
the debt we owe to the play of the
imagination
is incalculable
the bigger the crowd
the more negligible the individual
becomes
in each of us there is another whom we
do not know
the true leader
is always led
if the path before you is clear
you're probably on someone else's
nobody as long as he moves among the
chaotic currents of life
is without trouble
the majority of my patients consisted
not of believers
but of those who had lost their faith
faith hope
love and insight
are the highest achievements of human
effort
they are found given by experience
the fool is the precursor to the savior
often the hands will solve a mystery
that the intellect has struggled with in
vain
people don't have ideas
ideas have people
we cannot change anything unless we
accept it
condemnation does not liberate
it oppresses
a creative person has little power over
his own life
he is not free
he is captive and driven by his demon
intuition does not denote something
contrary to reason
but
something outside the province of reason
we hope for your support in the form of
likes and comments
thank you for watching